wondering how much a revenue-based
funding option could cost your business
let's break it down in a way that's easy
to understand and could save you a lot
of headaches when it comes to
revenue-based funding the cost is based
on a unique rate called a factor rate
think of this as the magic number that
determines how much you'll pay back
Factor rates typically range from 1.18
to
1.55 but what does that really mean for
you let's say your business is approved
for
$30,000 depending on your Factor rate
your repayment could range between $
35,400 and
$46,500
yep that's
$5,400 to
$16,500 extra all determined by your
Factor rate now you might be asking what
factor rate will I get well that depends
on how strong your business performance
is the better your numbers the better
your rate but wait there's more some
funding providers might include an
origination fee which is like a setup
charge ranging anywhere from 0 to 5% of
the advanced amount on a $30,000 Advance
that's an extra 0 to
$1,500 right off the top since not all
providers include this fee it's crucial
to verify with your provider whether
they do or not after all it's better to
know upfront before agreeing or signing
anything than to find out later when
it's too late to change your mind
ultimately here's the bottom line
revenue-based funding can be a Lifeline
for many businesses but knowing the real
cost is key to making the right decision
the better informed you are the better
you can plan for Success got questions
drop them in the comments and let's chat
about it